AMBER STEVENS WEST: Look at us.
Hi, everyone.
You made it out.
We made it out.
DARA WILSON: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Wow, that was so weak, you guys.
AUDIENCE: I know.
Sorry.
DARA WILSON: Hello!
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
No, no, honestly.
The first one was better.
It was so genuine.
It was like, yeah, hello.
You haven't done anything yet.
It was a response of
like, yeah, all right.
DARA WILSON: In anticipation
of this amazing panel
that's about to happen.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I don't clap
until the artist has performed.
I don't care who comes up.
I'd be the only one at Michael
Jackson show just like,
yeah, but dance first.
I'm sorry.
DARA WILSON: OK, I think
we're all warmed up now.
I am Dara Wilson.
I am a Googler here in
sunny Mountain View.
We're here with some folks
from "Carmichael Show."
We have Jerrod Carmichael,
Amber Stevens West, Ravi Nandan,
and Ari Katcher.
ARI KATCHER: Hi.
DARA WILSON: Yay!
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Hi, you guys.
DARA WILSON: Really grateful
that you guys are here with us
today.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Thanks for having us.
DARA WILSON: Yeah.
So I guess I just
want to get started
with how did the show become?
How did it get created?
What was that process like?
AMBER STEVENS WEST: I had
nothing to do with it.
DARA WILSON: Start with the
little questions first, right?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: What's
the fastest way of saying it?
I met NBC in like 2011.
Ari and co-created the
show, and Ravi just
really jumped on
board pretty much
since the onset of the idea.
He helped us develop it.
And we did a pilot
presentation that didn't go.
And then we did a pilot,
and then that worked.
DARA WILSON: And that's it?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah.
ARI KATCHER: And
now we're at Google.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah.
And then there's like two
years missing in that story.
It was a lot.
DARA WILSON: Cool.
So your background, Jerrod,
is in stand-up, and comedy,
obviously.
What is the biggest difference
going from that world
to television?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: It's
acceptance of a team effort.
I mean, as a stand-up,
you're alone,
and you write, and
perform, and direct,
and do all of the things.
And then, this is a team effort.
And so really surrounding
yourself with people
that you trust to move
toward one vision.
So I think, for me, that was
the thing-- accepting the moving
pieces.
DARA WILSON: And
how is that going?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: It's OK.
I trust everybody
right on this panel.
That ain't I nothing.
That's really strong.
Then it starts
getting real thin.
No, we have some
really wonderful people
that work with us.
And it's good.
I think we all learn what
the vision is, and then move
toward it.
DARA WILSON: So how is your
guys' working style together?
RAVI NANDAN: I mean, I think
it's all slightly different.
Obviously, Jerrod and
Ari created the show,
so they work, I think,
hand-in-hand pretty much
through every episode.
There's a writers room, and
they'll write everything,
but then-- yeah, exactly.
Lots of sleepovers-
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Like almost
a disgusting amount of time.
And yeah, so I
mean, Ravi produces,
and me and Ari write a lot of
the most-- how do we word this?
ARI KATCHER: I
mean, we spend a lot
of time in the writer's room.
Everybody pitches
ideas, and we talk
about what we want
the topics to be,
what we want to talk about
throughout the season.
And then we'll go
off, and we'll write,
and then we spend
a lot of weekends.
We do a lot of writing over
not sleeping on the weekend.
Because, yes, I mean he's
performing in the show too.
So I mean, he's
wearing a lot of hats.
So throughout the week,
he's memorizing the lines.
So on the weekend, that's
really the time for him
to put his voice, I
think, into the show.
So I'll come over to
his place, and we just
won't sleep for
an entire weekend,
and we'll just find
a way to make sure
that it sounds like
Jerrod's voice,
and make sure that the dialogue
sounds like it's coming
from him, from an honest place.
And that's our process, I think.
RAVI NANDAN: We tape this
show on Thursday nights.
And then the next
day, on Fridays,
we'll do a table read for
the next week's episode.
And from that, you guys will
rewrite over the weekend.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Yeah, exactly.
Two tapings Thursdays,
4:00 and 7:00.
I mean, it's really nonstop.
Because I mean, in the
middle of the season,
we may be simultaneously
working on like three episodes--
the one we're currently
going, and then trying
to be ahead for the
next one, and then
an idea for the next one.
So it's really a
grueling, nonstop process
of just incessant
thought and work.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah,
it's very unmotivating.
Thursday night,
you finish a show,
and then you're like,
hey, we did it-- oh, fuck.
We've gotta be up
in the morning.
We have to be up to read
the next episode tomorrow.
DARA WILSON: And, Amber,
I want to hear from you.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Yep, thank you.
Yeah, I didn't create
anything, so I don't have
much to contribute on that end.
DARA WILSON: But so
what's your experience
been like on the show, versus
some of the other places you've
been?
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
I should, right?
AMBER STEVENS WEST: Yeah, right?
Well, I'm sitting with all the
people in charge of my job.
It's the best work
experience I've ever had.
I've always wanted
to work in multicam.
It's such a different animal
than any single camera
drama, movie, any other thing
you could do as an actor.
So I'm having the best time.
I'm working with
the smartest people.
And it's a really
supportive environment.
We just have a lot of fun.
And so it's great to work
on something that's fun,
but also I'm proud of the
work that we are doing.
What we're making, I think,
is smart, and important,
and interesting,
and all of that.
So I love it.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Well, the
reason, I said I should leave
is because she also has the
burden of we tape on Thursdays,
and there are some Thursday
mornings where it's essentially
a new script.
AMBER STEVENS
WEST: That happens.
That happens, where we learn
an entire show in, like, six
hours.
That's happened.
But the thing is, is I
ever complain about it,
because it always gets better.
Every time there's a
change to the script,
it's a better version of what
we've been rehearsing all week.
So it's exciting.
It's nice like, OK, now
it's finally flowing better,
and it's making more
sense, and as a whole,
it's just going to
be a better product.
DARA WILSON: So
you guys do record
in front of a live audience?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah, it's
important. we're performers.
We all have somewhat of a
background in live performance.
The whole cast-- David
Alan Grier, Loretta Devine,
and Amber, and Rel, and
Tiffany all, our performance,
it works for us.
It plays toward
our instinct to be
able to perform in front of
the live studio audience,
and you get to immediately
gauge whether or not
the material's working.
You can feel when a story lags.
You can feel it,
and it allows us
to even-- we rewrite not
only up until tape night,
but in between shows,
we do a 4:00 and a 7:00,
and we'll rewrite based off of
audience response, based off
of feeling, based off
of a lot of things.
So just always trying
to go toward whatever
the truth of that episode is.
RAVI NANDAN: And doing the
double taping, the 4:00
and the 7:00, hasn't been done
since "Cheers" or something
like that.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Yeah, it's been a while.
RAVI NANDAN: It
is that reason, so
that you can fine
tune it and perform it
in front of one audience.
Do it straight through once,
and see what works and what
doesn't, and then have about two
hours to do a rewrite of it .
AMBER STEVENS WEST: It's genius.
I don't know why all
multicams don't do it.
RAVI NANDAN: Yeah.
It makes a big difference.
Especially from the
performing side, too.
It's fun that we
get the jitters out.
We test it out first with an
audience, and then by the time
we get to the second show,
we can relax, and do it,
and have a lot of fun.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
But you're right.
Because it's a lot more work.
Another thing that you learn is
that people are fucking lazy.
That's why a lot of
things don't get done.
People are just terrified
of an extra step.
And that's why we're
so excited about.
A lot of the staff and
everyone who works on the show,
we're excited about really
trying to give 100%,
as cliche as that sounds.
But it really is just trying
to put a lot of effort,
and a lot of thought into it.
ARI KATCHER: I
would say even 110.
[LAUGHTER]
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
I gave 110 once.
ARI KATCHER: Yeah,
don't do that again.
DARA WILSON: You look like
you threw out your back.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I did.
I did.
DARA WILSON: So you're getting
that feedback from the audience
live.
You guys also really
interact with the audience
through digital means,
through social media.
So how much of an
impact does that
have on the things that you
decide to talk about, what you
don't, and how the show goes?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Amber
engages more than--
AMBER STEVENS WEST: I just
like everything on Twitter
that I see.
I go through, and anything with
the hashtag Carmichael Show,
I like, like, like.
I don't know from
your end, though.
I don't know if
they have any input.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: No.
No, not at all.
But I do think--
if it's more rooted
in conversation, like where
the shows and the episodes
and stuff comes from, it's
more rooted in conversations
that I've had or that we've
had, or very interesting topics
or whatever just won't go away,
whatever we found interesting,
whatever source of contention
in our lives becomes an episode.
DARA WILSON: So then
how much of what
you are saying in the
show, what you feel,
and then what's
happening around you,
like conversations
you've actually had?
Or are you sometimes putting
on the hat of somebody else?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I don't know.
A lot about my stand-up
and perspective
is in me and other characters.
It's sometimes like David
gets a lot of my stand-up
and perspective and
stuff like that.
And some scenes
have been arguments
that I've have with myself,
just seeing both sides of it.
So I don't know.
ARI KATCHER: I mean,
you'll do that.
I mean, even stand up, you'll
sometimes take something,
and then you'll
be like, you know,
and on the other
hand, sometimes this.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I'll just
immediately contradict myself.
ARI KATCHER: You'll
argue the other end.
So it's almost easy to do that,
because I've heard you argue.
And even in conversations,
we'll just be arguing something,
and then you'll be like, but
also totally the opposite too.
We're never too precious
about the point that we make.
It's always more about
the fun of arguing.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: You guys
should hear my thoughts
on global warming.
ARI KATCHER: Great place for it.
DARA WILSON: You're just really
rigorous and scientific, right?
That's what your
thoughts are like.
ARI KATCHER: But I mean,
just looking at everything
from every point of view,
and being able to assign that
to different characters.
RAVI NANDAN: Have you had
a point of view in the show
that you fully don't believe?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: No.
that's a lot of times
what I'd rewrite if I
don't feel a connection to it.
Then it just doesn't
stand a lot of times.
Because I not need to
be able to genuinely
argue it, and be able to feel
passionate about whatever
we're talking about.
So a lot of the
rewrites have just
been trying to find prospective.
Either I've given out
too much of my own
amongst other
characters, and then I
have to refind what it is.
But for the most part,
I feel pretty strongly
about most of the
things I've said.
DARA WILSON: What
about you, Amber?
How much are you like Maxine?
Are you the Maxine
of your family?
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
That's a good question.
AMBER STEVENS WEST: Am I
the Maxine of my family?
No, I come from a very open
minded, liberal family.
So everything that I
get to say on the show,
I pretty much agree with,
with the exception, I think,
of probably a couple things.
But I relate in point
of view with Maxine.
And my family does too.
So it's really easy.
There's actually
been times where,
you know how you
believe in something,
but you've never really asked
yourself why you believe in it?
You've never questioned
your beliefs?
DARA WILSON: It's just
what Mom and Dad said.
AMBER STEVENS WEST: It's just
something that you think,
and you've never really had
much of a discussion with anyone
about why.
There's a lot of times where
this show, my character says
why she believes something, and
then I myself, in real life,
go, oh, that's why
I believe that.
So I'm learning about myself.
through their writing.
DARA WILSON: That's great.
I mean, can that
be tense, though?
Because the characters
disagree a lot.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
That's the whole point.
DARA WILSON: They're at very
opposite ends of the issues.
So does that tension cross over?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Oh, so
then we just hate each other?
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Like real life?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Fuck you.
You know what you did.
DARA WILSON: Well, it's
like, you see somebody,
they play a role a little bit
too well, and it's like, oh,
you're a slavemaster.
You just like--
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Everyone
was terrified of Fassbender
of the set of the "12."
No, I don't think so.
Yeah, I don't think so.
But I think that I also
my family really likes
to argue for sport as well.
We're those types of people.
The night before
out last taping,
I was really, really
tired, and I was exhausted.
And my sister called me,
and brought up "Lemonade."
Right?
Because whose sister didn't?
And she was talking about it.
And I said, oh, did
my niece see it?
My niece is about turn nine, and
loves Beyonce, and plays piano.
And I was like, did she see it?
She should experience it as
part of a cultural thing.
And I'm arguing with my sister.
And it was like, no
it's too adult for her.
And I argued with my sister
for legitimately an hour
and a half.
Exhausted, an hour
and a half, I argued.
And then yesterday,
she called me.
And she was just
like, oh yeah, no.
She had already seen it by
the time I talked to her.
But it shows that I
needed to know why
you thought I should show her.
Why did you think?
And I'm just all passionate.
She's an artist!
I'm screaming.
She's making me defend
Beyonce's album for her.
DARA WILSON:
Opposition research.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Just in normal life.
She was just like, but I needed
to know why you thought that.
DARA WILSON: There has
to be an undercurrent
of a lot of love there.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Yeah, there has to be.
Because I fucking
hated her after that.
But it's fun, though.
It's fun.
You want to know why-- I
mean, like you were saying,
why you feel a certain way,
and get to your own truth.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
I was just saying,
I think what's unique about our
show is that we are a family
dynamic on the show.
It's not just a group of friends
with difference of opinion.
So I think that's
the safest place.
You can be yourself.
And like you were saying, you
can fight with your sister,
but at the end of the
day, she's your sister.
And you can be as bluntly
honest as you want to.
And I think that's why you
get such honest perspective
within our show.
Because at the end
of the day, they're
all going to come back together,
and they're going to be family,
but they can argue to the death.
To the pain, maybe, yeah.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Also I'm
realizing, as I'm talking,
my apologies.
You have to explicitly tell
me no cursing in order for me
not to say curse words, as
much as I've been saying.
But I don't think
I've heard that.
RAVI NANDAN: I feel like
you may say more after that.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
I listen for it.
As a comic, if you don't
say "no cursing," if someone
doesn't, walking in a church,
you've got to tell me.
DARA WILSON: I I think it's OK.
We're all adults here.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: OK, good.
DARA WILSON: Are
anyone's ears hurting?
Y'all are good.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: OK.
I got really
self-conscience about it.
DARA WILSON: So the
show is breaking
new ground, not just
because of the stuff
that you're talking about, but
because you are a black family
having these conversations.
How important is it to you,
whatever responsibility there
is to be representing a
black family on television?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I
have a responsibility
to do an honest
portrayal of a family,
and to be true to
my experiences,
and true to the
people that I've met,
and the people that I know.
And so finding the
beauty in that honesty
is where my obligation lies.
Because a lot of times
when representing
any group of people,
a creator can
tend to go so
aspirational that they get
further away from the truth.
After "The Cosby Show,"
like it's like, OK,
there's not that
many black lawyers.
There's black doctors.
You know what I mean?
It's not representing
a truth anymore.
As with the Hillman
shirt right there.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA WILSON: That's my
attorney mother, so--
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
No, but, no, but I'm
saying it has to be bent.
A lot of times, it
goes so aspirational
that it stops being--
DARA WILSON: Yeah, you have
"The Cosby Show," and then--
JERROD CARMICHAEL: You
need "The Cosby Show,"
and you also need that balance.
And so a lot of times, I didn't
see the very honest portrayal
of the full spectrum of what a
black family is on television.
So that was really fun to do.
DARA WILSON: All right.
I think that's an
acceptable answer.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
We could debate more.
I'm real happy to.
Oh yeah.
DARA WILSON: No, no, no.
That was great.
Are there any things that
you haven't covered yet
that you want to?
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
There are always
questions and these
hypothetical type
questions that'll
come up that you
can build an episode around.
So like my stand-up,
a lot of times
a topical thing will lead
to a deeper question.
So I mean, we did
episode on Bill Cosby,
but it really wasn't
about Bill Cosby.
It was really about
talent versus morals.
And so finding those
pockets of question
is where we find things.
So that happens every day.
And it happens a
lot where you just
have an interesting question
that you want to see answered.
DARA WILSON: Anything else?
You guys looking
forward to covering
any things in particular?
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
I'm excited for people
to see episodes that
have not aired yet.
I mean, I'm not in
the writer's room.
I don't know what
they're coming up with,
but there's one that we just
shot that was hysterical.
Am I allowed to say
what we're doing?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah.
AMBER STEVENS WEST: There's
one that we did about porn.
And our table read
was so hilarious,
and everyone was
bright red in the room.
And we had to stop
for long pauses
of uncomfortable laughter.
It was the most fun.
And it's just a subject
that you don't really
talk about, especially
with your family,
but it's something that you
don't even really talk about
with your friends,
especially women.
So I'm excited to
even see it myself.
I haven't seen it.
ARI KATCHER: Yeah, I
mean, just anything.
Anything where you can
ask yourself a question,
and say, I don't know the
answer to that question
is good territory.
Because we don't like
to end episodes on,
well, here's the actual
answer, or here's the thing.
So any time it's literally
impossible to know the answer,
it's just difference of
opinion, is a good territory.
So in that porn episode, I
was so excited to do that porn
episode.
Because there is that
question that I don't know.
Is it OK?
I Is it fine that we
are watching porn?
Is it not OK that
we're watching porn?
Does it affect you badly?
There's all these questions.
I've had these conversations
with you and other friends
and stuff like
that, but any time
you can find a
subject like that,
it's really, really exciting.
When you yourself
don't know the answer,
you know it's going
to be a good, to me.
DARA WILSON: Was there
any particular episode
that you were nervous
about when it came out?
Or were you just like,
this is what I have to say.
You're going to hear it.
I don't care what you think.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: No, that's
the benefit of being stand-up.
There's nothing we can do an
episode about that I haven't
completely alienated a group
of people in a dark room with.
So it's nothing.
I mean, what else can we?
ARI KATCHER: Yeah, no.
Everything seems-- there
have definitely been topics
that other people
were nervous about,
but I don't know if I've
ever felt that myself.
RAVI NANDAN: There's
also been points of view
that are interesting, that
maybe are unexpected in a way,
that you're like, how are
people going to react to this?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah.
ARI KATCHER: I've been I've been
excited to see how, especially
David Alan Grier in the
protest episode and stuff
like that, I was excited to see
what people's reactions were
going to be.
And I don't know.
There's something
exciting about maybe
somebody doesn't like
that you said a thing
or something like that.
I think that's always positive.
RAVI NANDAN: I think that's one
of the most interesting things
about the show, the
different points of view,
and that you're not
always going to agree
with everybody's point of view.
DARA WILSON: Probably impossible
to agree with everybody's point
of view on the show.
ARI KATCHER: Yeah, it should be.
RAVI NANDAN: It should be.
Yeah, exactly.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah, I think
finding that balanced argument
is where it's fun.
Because the content you
receive shouldn't be mindless.
And that's what
the sitcom became.
It became mindless.
You just receive it,
and it's mindless.
You don't have to think
about what's being said,
or what the story is.
You could just watch
it, and you go to sleep.
But to make people agree, or
disagree, or feel anything
is important and
really exciting.
DARA WILSON: So
is that something
you think about, even
on a character basis?
Like when somebody is about
to say something that may not
be palatable to
other people, how
do you maintain the
humanity of that character
while having them say
some outlandish things?
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
I mean, I think
that's where knowing how
much they love each other,
and knowing who they
are as a person,
and trying to establish that
first, before views are laid
out, allows you to
go, all right, well,
we know that this guy
loves his girlfriend.
This guy love his
wife or vice versa.
And so even if they're
saying the most absurd thing,
we know that there is
love and respect there.
ARI KATCHER: Knowing
that there's love,
and knowing that it's
honest, knowing that
what you like to see, or at
least what I like to see on TV,
is people saying things that
you would relate to, but be
a thought that you
would have had,
but were maybe too scared
to say in a certain moment.
And you get to watch these
people actually say the thing
that you were thinking.
The time when it's offensive
is when there's no thought,
and it's just stupid.
That's why just random
stereotype jokes or something
like that feel more offensive.
Because they're not smart.
As long as something
comes from a thought,
I don't feel like
it's as offensive.
So when you can be
like, oh, I understand
how that person could think that
way, or could feel that way,
maybe I disagree with
it, but I understand
where it's coming from.
As long as you understand
where someone's coming from,
as long as you can have some
sort of empathy for them,
I think that you're not going
to hate them for saying it.
RAVI NANDAN: I also
think s much of it
is owed to the performances too.
ARI KATCHER: Oh yeah.
RAVI NANDAN: Our actors
do such a good job
of really taking it on and
believing those points of view,
too, so that they come off
from a very sincere and honest
place.
DARA WILSON: I know
that all of the episodes
are personally relevant
to you because they're
coming from you,
but for any of you,
was there any one particular
episode that really hit home
with you, that felt
especially important?
AMBER STEVENS WEST: You'd have
to list all the episodes to me.
We've done so many, and
they're all so great,
and they've got their own
special moments in each of them
that I identify with and
sparked something in me.
I literally can't even
remember what we've done now.
RAVI NANDAN: Yeah.
I mean, I feel like
almost every one,
there's a piece
that rings for me.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Yeah, there's always
something in each episode.
RAVI NANDAN: People in my family
have battled depression, so
that one.
Gun control's always such a big
thing, no matter where you are,
I feel.
Obviously, Cosby,
grew up with Cosby,
and the whole
conversation is one
that I feel I have every
day around other things.
AMBER STEVENS WEST: I liked
our Islamophobia one a lot.
I thought that one was
a pretty poignant thing
that we don't
discuss enough that's
going on a lot in our
country right now.
That one I thought was
great, well handled.
Yeah.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Thank you.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
You're welcome.
[LAUGHTER]
DARA WILSON: Cool.
And then I guess on
a more general level,
what is the one thing that
you are most excited about,
about having this opportunity
to work with these people?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I
mean, just the day to day
is really fun, the
process and the fact
that it is this Rubik's cube,
where it's always a piece
that you have to figure out.
I always need to be challenged,
and so, in a general sense,
just having something
to figure out every day
was really exciting.
And being around people
that are just like-minded,
trying to help you
solve it is really fun.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
What was the question?
Why is it so fun?
I'm It's just so fun.
It's so fun.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: But word
it in such a more articulate--
AMBER STEVENS
WEST: No, we really
work with a really
special group of people.
Everyone is so talented,
and so much fun,
and excited about what
they do every single day.
I mean, I don't ever
want to go home.
When we have hiatus week,
I'm like, it's too long.
I want to go back to work.
Because we have so
much fun together.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Oh,
you're [INAUDIBLE].
AMBER STEVENS WEST: We
just had a great time,
and there's not one bad seed.
I mean, literally,
from every crew member,
to writer, to actor,
it's like we all
are one big happy family.
And so it's a blast getting
to get together and make
these interesting shows.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I
bet that now next week,
they headline-- Loretta
Devine stabs David Alan Grier.
I thought things were
sweet and delightful there.
ARI KATCHER: Favorite
thing about the show?
I hate sleeping.
So it's been great that
I don't have to do it.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
No sleeping this year.
RAVI NANDAN: It's
for your insomnia?
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Again,
90 minutes is effective.
You hit REM, you get
in there, you get out.
Get a cup of coffee, and
hit the ground running.
I'm on 90 minutes right now.
I'm really excited.
Not even that.
I'm on, like, 35, and I'm
really happy right now.
DARA WILSON: Well, you're
delirious, but that's OK.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Potato, patata.
RAVI NANDAN: He won't
remember any of this.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I
will remember that, dude.
It will be a nightmarish
dream that I wake up from.
Actually, I want
to redo "Being John
Malkovich" based on that dude.
Go inside of his head,
experience what he has.
ARI KATCHER: No, that you get
to work really hard on a thing
that you like.
I don't know.
Because if you had to work
that hard on something
that you didn't like,
it would b so brutal.
Because I mean, it's long
hours, and it's hard.
But then you get to see the
thing that you worked hard on,
and you're excited about
it, and you enjoy it.
And yeah, that's
really, really great.
Yeah, it makes it worth it.
RAVI NANDAN: I think it's
great to be part of a show that
can be part of the conversation,
that talks about issues
in a way that's
funny, and sincere,
and is hopefully
getting a point across.
And I think that's a
rare thing in TV today.
DARA WILSON: Cool.
Well, I think we have time
for some audience questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Camille.
Super fan.
I have to admit,
though, I started
DVRing because of Loretta
Devine and David Alan Grier.
It's the childhood dream team
JERROD CARMICHAEL: We get it.
We get it.
AUDIENCE: So I'm married, and
I'm married to a Sicilian man.
And your show and shows like
it help the conversations.
Because somehow I
represent all of America,
all of black America, all of
California, all of Georgia.
I'm Southern.
So I have to represent
a lot of things.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: That's a
lot of weight on your shoulders
right there.
AUDIENCE: So I thank
you for bringing
the Southern, the
black perspective,
having characters
like my parents,
like things I really relate
to that make our conversations
just easier.
So I want to say thank you.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I have a request.
I don't know who this goes to.
It has happened twice, but the
funeral episode specifically,
Loretta Devine, I was
waiting for her to sing.
I mean, she can sing.
And I was OK she
didn't know the words.
But just let her--
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Let her go.
Let me tell you something.
You say of that.
ARI KATCHER: Loretta'll
bring the house down.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
How can I say this?
You gotta reel Loretta in.
Loretta will just sing, and
then everybody's all emotional.
It's hard.
You know, it's funny.
I used to watch shows that would
have a musical performance.
It's hard to realistically
squeeze that in.
Do you know what I mean?
ARI KATCHER: A whole song.
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
I would love to.
We get these snippets,
but it's hard.
It was always like,
I would shows,
and it always gets too corny.
In that moment, it's
just like, and now we're
going to do a four minute
just a song right now.
ARI KATCHER: It could
be an amazing throwback.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah.
All right.
I guess we'll do a song.
It's really difficult.
RAVI NANDAN: The moment
where she sings in protest
is pretty incredible.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Yeah.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
I'm never sick of it.
We play "Protest"
before a lot of our tape
nights for the audience
when they come in.
And so we can always
hear it backstage,
hear Loretta singing.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Because
we like getting people
in the mood for a comedy.
Hey, you want to play the one
where a black kid gets shots
by a cop.
Right before the comedy?
I think that's a good idea.
Let me do that.
More Loretta singing?
If you think that
Loretta doesn't
pitch us doing
musicals, she pitches
us doing a musical episode
at least once a week.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
At least once a week.
That's not a joke.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: So when we
gonna do this musical thing?
Reprise songs from "Dreamgirls."
All right.
I'm like, relax.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I'm Greg.
Thanks so much for coming out.
I'm just now embarking
upon my acting career
here in the Bay Area as well.
And so I just wanted
to know if there
are any specific techniques,
such as the Meisner technique
or what have you, that are
really useful for television.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Ooh.
AMBER STEVENS
WEST: OK, well, I'm
not a classically
trained actor, but I
can say, the best thing that
you can ever learn to do
is learn on camera technique.
Know that you have
to catch light.
This stuff's all important.
They don't tell you this.
Look, when you get
on a set, there's
a light you have to stand near.
Because you're going to
get shadowed by something.
So you have to learn about that.
ARI KATCHER: I didn't
even know that.
AMBER STEVENS WEST: You have
to learn how to get to a mark
without looking at a mark.
And you also have to learn how
to learn lines really fast.
I think those are the
most important things
that you need as an everyday
skill as a working actor.
So there are on camera
classes that you can take.
Cold reading class, I
think is really helpful.
It just works your brain.
It gets you used to memorizing
something really quickly.
You even learn your own tricks.
But that's as deep
as I go as an actor.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Learning
your tricks is probably
the most important.
I don't really like classes,
and I have my questions
about formal
education in general.
But we don't have time.
It more so addles your brain
than fosters creativity.
It makes us all sheep.
Yadda-yadda-yadda-yadda.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Makes us all sheep.
DARA WILSON: It's an audience
full of addled brains.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: No,
but I'm just saying,
you have to be cautious.
You have to guard
your own creativity
in any type of class,
any type of technique.
If you look at a
lot of the stories
from your favorite
actors, you actually
will learn that they dropped out
of class, like De Niro, Pacino,
Denzel Washington-- people
that did class, got what they
needed, and then just split.
Because wherever the voids
are, you fill those voids in,
and you be really
honest with yourself
with your own strengths
and weaknesses.
And if all else fails, hire
somebody like David Alan Grier
to just do the lion's share
of the acting work for you.
[INAUDIBLE]
But yeah, I don't
know if there's
anything in particular
for sitcom acting,
but in general, Meisner's
method, or is that Strasberg?
RAVI NANDAN: That's Strasberg.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: Strasberg's
method, I would say that.
If you're going to play
a heroine addict, man,
do some heroine, man.
Go in there.
Live life.
Go for it.
DARA WILSON: We can't undersign
any of this as Google, but--
JERROD CARMICHAEL: If
you think that people
who have the idea
to create Google
hadn't dabbled in
a couple drugs--
DARA WILSON: We just
saw the guy outside.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for the show.
We found it maybe
about four months ago,
and we watched
every single episode
we could get our hands on.
So that was pretty awesome.
My question is,
where do you guys see
the show going in the future?
And I do have one request,
and the request is,
I'd like to see more
of the brother's--
JERROD CARMICHAEL:
Loretta singing.
AUDIENCE: No.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: We get it!
You want a [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's not my request.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to see more
of your brother's baby mama.
I think she's funny.
AMBER STEVENS WEST: Tiffany.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
She's hilarious.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Tiffany's hilarious.
AUDIENCE: That's my question.
JERROD CARMICHAEL: All right.
Where do we see the show?
I mean, just again, just
staying honest to whatever
conversations we're
having and whatever topics
seem interesting.
It's no specific thing.
We're always trying to grow
and get better, and make
sure the chemistry,
and the rhythm,
and all those
things are stronger
in a more general sense,
but specifically just
staying close to the truth,
and staying close to things
that we feel passionate about.
And yes, more Tiffany.
More Tiffany.
She's great.
She's really fun to write for.
She just bursts in.
ARI KATCHER: She
is really funny.
DARA WILSON: Well, thank you all
so much for being here with us.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Thanks for having us.
RAVI NANDAN: Thanks
for having us.
AMBER STEVENS WEST:
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]